our theories have changed the back rooms
back in February shortly after Kane
pixels uploaded his first back rooms
video we did a film Theory offering
advice on how to survive a repeating
Maze of yellow walls and Soggy carpet
some key points in that video were
collecting useful objects from the world
around you writing on walls and knocking
down ceiling tiles to mark everywhere
that you've been guess what since that
theory there have been 11 new uploads
with tons of evidence that characters
are following my advice in pitfalls we
see an area where someone's collected a
backpack chairs shoes cardboard and
letters from signs that they could use
as Weapons or to Mark where they've been
and in one of the newest uploads reunion
we actually see a map that has been
carved into a wall as well as several
ceiling tiles that have been knocked out
of the ceiling why well so a lost async
employee could more easily find his way
around not saying that they're
necessarily following Our advice but
certainly looks like someone at async
has been watching our videos we also
suggested climbing into the vents to
find potential exits I wonder if we're
going to see that one in a future upload
because if that happens that is
undeniable proof that